just talking about sweat Oh sweat sweat
sweat wet in flesh from New York to New
York rat what a great time don't Gotham
for the sold-out shows yeehaw hey bro
yeah it's winter I'm into sweatshirts
are you yeah I'm gonna sweatshirts now
nice nice all nice and cozy dumb that's
a car that's a cot nice well what's that
say dude is that Chinese I don't think
that is China chin don't ask him what
that means - he's Korean knows more than
you oh my god I'm so offended right now
ah it's Japanese boom OH
Japanese cause this is Andre the Giant
when he performed in Japan oh cool yeah
is that roots of fight yes okay nice
yeah it is bro adorable I'm in the
sweatshirts all right man winter bro
you know he's you like you like sweater
weather yeah that's right I'm wearing my
ankle's bucks uh sweater weather
I don't like cold weather do you I like
crisp weather [ __ ] with my skin I have
dry scalp yeah I got dry everything do
you have dry dude at 50 I'm gonna be
completely honest with you you're
breaking up
yeah because what happens is Ojai know
you're gonna break it down we'll post
that picture with duck lips with Artie
Lange you both look yeah we look older
we're half a century dude mmm I see I
want to go it old there no rocky crackly
I won't go with crackling careful
what are you get why are you looking in
the sky why are you looking like you're
searching for a word when you have I'm
searching for a rudder looking up in the
homeland things like you're looking at
the Sun you guys look like to desert
toads that's fair and this is what
happens when you're 50 you let Caroline
water so today I was I was with my wife
and I looked in we're gonna go get
coffee and I swear to God I looked in
the window of a shop and I looked at my
face and I went I'm not going to get
coffee she goes why I go I don't know I
just don't feel good really I didn't
like when I look I was like man it
doesn't get better from here it just
gets you just get more wrinkly no got it
depends certain guy I mean you age like
wine man you're good for a 50-year I'm
not bad for a 50-year old now I did
knowing shits on you frank grillo
well yeah Frank's our boy of course
Frank do you know Jamie Foxx's 50 that
that he shits on you know who's 40 cent
shit's on both of you Oh jared leto I
look older than Jenny 747 look it up
he's in cry look older than Jenny he's
incredible I was watching the war shows
last night and I go [ __ ] I tell John
like you know he's like mid forties you
know I went 45 45 sylph 45 see he's a
beautiful man 45 I look 45 competitive I
know he has no bad tell you this I'll
tell you this right now say it out loud
watch that documentary Icarus I want to
find that scientist you want to tell you
some stuff I don't look at him 2080 2016
are you kidding me first of all look at
his eyes and then I've seen his hair
piercing blue eyes I'm just blown away
he looks exactly he hangs upside down
like a bat I think he drinks teenager
blood
he definitely drinks teenage teenager
blood that's crazy
no he doesn't he doesn't kill him he
just he just pays them to sit there and
drain their they just look like an IV
you just stay young leave it that crazy
yeah like you think you look good didn't
you see people actually age well good
his eyes wouldn't be funny if I just
dove it my voice got super high it's
like you just discovered your dilemma I
mean look at his hairs the face of Gucci
his hairs all fluffy on the top he is
yes Gucci's makes him clothes sends him
stuff really yeah he wears buckles on
his boots like you do oh yeah yeah I get
the idea
no he's your hero yeah he is he's here I
heard that man sing oh god actor fret
you know what 2005 was rough for him
gonna click on through in five picture
right there
all right yeah but can you ballgame bro
can you do me job doing right now oh
he's a cutie there no and I'm the middle
there no there he looks like you'd steal
your girl yeah he looks a little strange
there can you um like not not like steal
your girl in a bar like not kidnapped he
looks like he's he's been hypnotized I
think he looks like he just got out yeah
he's like no you look saying he involved
in some sort of cult in 1996 exactly
through the runner that's right on 15 he
looks like he's not all there yep that's
right
he's just an eyes the face of Gucci must
kill must kill ya - essays um if you
want to go back - let me see the
pictures because there's a picture of
him with his we're go up there where
he's fat skinny and muscular okay let me
get it let me get
in there that's not him sure is so
that's where he was pleased even Chapman
okay that's where he thought that we had
AIDS on the left in Irish Club yeah we
died yeah you gotta give it up to him
that's pretty impressive that's where
yeah that's where his plan he direct
yeah playing David Chapman look at his
body look I love a guy who's that
good-looking who's not afraid to look
ugly and then look at him there who you
paid a lot of money look ugly though
let's take it easy I don't know look at
him there though that's life come on
dude the hair no and he's shredded and
he sings I mean I'm gonna go home 30
seconds to market form a huge band there
he's a major actor that's just killing
it yeah congratulations
I bet I get any girls hey so how was New
York buddy I love speaking of Street
rats I old stopping down shows were
great all sold out of God Oh awesome
Gotham was amazing thank you for
everybody coming out and said that twice
now I hung with my boys with Jerry Jimmy
and dove Davidoff now did Joe stub awful
stories or no Jerry's a great story
Jimmy had great story that's Jerry's one
of the best storytellers remember I
think it was just last time I might have
been last time yeah yeah yeah
but overall he's a master storyteller we
had a laugh Jimmy
great Jimmy the greatest bike Jimmy
Burke the great the great the great that
the national advisor wonder of the one a
tional treasure the [ __ ] monk the man
who is always happy still single single
as [ __ ] and loving it talking about how
much sleep he gets now that he's single
I'm like okay he does not you know doves
in the doves in that new swing of
someone kill him it doesn't that new
Punisher
just showing Netflix Doug David off yeah
yeah dude he's on shades of blue he's on
crashing and now he's in the Punisher he
never stops working real estate mogul I
read his book Road Dogg get that book
Road Dogg I [ __ ] love but remember he
took like he's amazing two years off
remarried left Venice and stopped
writing he was just in the real absolute
comedy to who's writing that book he
started writing that book and doing real
estate now he set himself up is wealthy
smart dude yeah yeah Road yeah Road Dogg
I love the book I love the book so it's
a great example of what it's like to be
a stand-up comic really good
get it get it
Road Dogg get it read it or die that's
my plug he won't plug anything he's
still there you want to talk about a
guy's the worst in social media I'm like
have you done anything about the book
that you spent two years writing and you
you gotta let people know you were right
look I don't I never understand that I
get he's old-school but then if you're
gonna write why write the book if you
don't want people to read it
hey that's just that strength but don't
make sense to me like you have a
publisher and stuff it shouldn't just
right in your trap he can't do it like
right on the back of a napkin I'm like
you've got to be a little bit better
with social media I sound like you to me
and he's there's levels to this game he
just can't do it and I have sympathy
because I remember I being that way yeah
and I think what it is is that sometimes
the idea of self-promotion for a
comedian who already hates himself part
of what makes him so funny is this own
like a psychiatrist said to dev one time
do you think that you do you feel you
don't have a right to exist and he went
he thought about anyway I think that's
exactly how I feel like he goes
the guy hit it on the [ __ ] heads it's
like he encapsulated his whole life
let's run this childhood I promise
traffic yeah so when you have a guy like
that who has put that in the comedy was
the reason I love his comedy yeah you're
asking him to to tout his they write a
book that's not in your home dude this
is the take it's a stand-up this is the
great complication of human TV because
we're all crazy because we all have
these we all have these competing values
in our head right we do something we
want to be famous but we don't want to
be famous we want to be successful but
we hate success you know we'll look at
money money money is a classic example
of people who want to make money but
they have so many negative connotations
to money right money is the root of all
evil what if I don't have time to spend
it money can't buy you happiness we have
a lot of negative [ __ ] around money get
people want money so so one of the
things that likely depends who it is but
but it's deep in us like like even in
Christianity the idea what what did
Christ say it's harder for a rich man to
enter the gates of heaven than it is for
a camel to pass through the eye of a
needle that's from the Bible in other
words a rich man you know the famous
story of the rich man saying I want to
go to heaven or I want to be party and
he said well give up all your money and
the rich man bowed his head
walked away said it there's always been
this idea that money is the root of all
evil money is they follow the money
maybe I why are people dying follow the
money how many movies have you seen that
finally you realize I they're making
money off of this so the in depends on
you Lucas you give them find a lot of
cases like Bill Gates will follow the
money or them so really really really
well rich people who do really well in
our this is the great and very
interesting sort of thing about our
society we are a capitalist society
consumer society we worship money we all
want to make money but at the same time
if you see people who make a lot of
money they don't have those hangups
they've done a lot of studies on like
Tony Robbins was talking about this
they've done a lot of those
psychological profiles on people who so
one of the things that when he gives a
wealth seminar is that he'll say the
first thing you have to do is condition
yourself to believe that you deserve to
have money and a lot of psychiatrists
talk about this because you will there
are so much baggage around money for a
lot of people a lot of people and and
you know people stop themselves but look
we talked about this all time how many
actors like my acting teacher used to
love to find he'd get you out in front
of him they go they've really talented
people [ __ ] like like blow you away at
a scene how come you're not working well
you know I got the thing they think that
and then he would do this he'd start
asking questions and he'd start going
he'd start counting and next thing you
know he'd have on his fingers he'd count
five or ten things that were insuring
this person's failure from the Dutch
they said yes from the person they were
dating yeah well what we do is we go I
want to be famous so I want to be an
actor I want to be a working actor right
you really want that but then what you
do for whatever reason is you find a
thousand things to do procrastinate to
not get your goal so you'll date
somebody that takes a ball you're mostly
sometimes you'll get a job that's that
you need but be sometimes without these
people that go I won't be an actor they
don't realize what entails being an
actor they see whatever movie inspired
them Shawshank of Fifty Shades of Grey
you know I won't be an actor now yeah
that that mode may be an actor yeah
then you get and you realize it's not
that's there's so much more that goes
along with that right let's by the way
let's accept one of the reasons well you
know you don't present your past you
know what Paredes principle is
you've heard of that peretta was a an
economist and he was growing peas in his
backyard and he found that 20% of his
the pods created 80% of the Peas
so a lot of times 20% of your effort so
if you look at all your effort 20% of
what you're doing is actually creating
really missing a few results
yeah and so the idea is to get and then
a lot of times you're spending 80% of
your time on the 20% of the employees
there that are causing you all the
problems do we fire those employees okay
what's interesting is that I was reading
in the barber shop this article in
Rolling Stone you won't you won't know
her at all so I'll get you on it but it
has something to do you'll see the
correlation here her name's cardi B
ready for this lover so you do you
definitely well she's amazing cardi B
was a stripper not famous stripper but
just a stripper body dumped in New York
but from Brooklyn I think and she got on
the show love and hip hop she's not a
vocalist she's not a rapper she got in
love and hip hop cuz she's kind of in
that scene whatever she's this brought
by far the breakout star of this show
it's a reality show but and I watched
the shows and why I liked her cuz she
was really good tel like someone tell
her to say something she'd go the exact
opposite she'd say outlandish [ __ ] like
date someone goes man you know you're
getting kind of get a little more famous
your teeth reflect up they should [ __ ]
your teeth up she goes I almost sucked
dick the same huh then she's dead
serious like she just butch it's like
very organic yeah she's out she's flim
like outlandish and like loud like an
honest you like her yeah you can tell
it's not real like the rest of the cast
yeah so she comes this breakout star
she's again not a music anything like
that she just beat Taylor Swift for the
number one single in the world white and
she's like insane famous now insane
famous so this wrote this she's gorgeous
by the way
yeah she looks like Usher a little bit
how dare you that's racist but whatever
so she is this insane star now and she
has the number one hit called boudic
yellow there she is her body's
ridiculous but it's her personality
being interacts and stuff like that so
so she's doing these shows now show she
only has one Julie
one song she's not alerts this she's not
someone wrote it for someone came with
team and she's doing it and she's in her
hotel and they're talking to her doing
the interview and she's like I hate this
so glass doesn't give me a yeast
infection she just talked about how they
need change so and the interviewers like
Jesus Christ man like she's all over so
she goes and does this concert comes
back and she was saying how she's like
she's a negative person by it by nature
and how she she can feel the pressure of
the music industry and all the fans who
are like kind of hating our she has this
instant success she's like man I didn't
I don't want to do this man like yeah
and she goes now I can't get on famous
cuz I don't know what to do and she feel
so much pressure cuz it was overnight
she beat Taylor Swift that's so nuts so
many people are hating on they're like
you're not real lyrics is in all this
she's like no [ __ ] I'm not not yeah no
[ __ ]
so now but she has to make it she'll
have an album so now she has to make a
debut album she's she goes I'm in
there's so much stress now because I
feel like after deliver and she goes I
don't like writing music but I have to
come up with this album now guy and she
was I don't wanna be one-hit wondering
like I don't want the money go away I
can't get on famous can't walk down the
street she's like it's just I didn't
expect any of this yeah you know there's
something lease is 25 there's something
really refreshing about people are
completely honest we you know you and I
talk about that like I've always said I
don't want any secrets my friends know
everything about me I don't walk around
with secrets like I don't want people to
know they but my friends know my good in
my bad would you say you'd sure like you
tried you try to be in there's something
very liberating about be honest shoot
she's talking about how again now her
fame is written she was like millions
and millions of fathers now on Instagram
Twitter but she was saying how she was
always off the cuff like that and she
tweeted out like Kim yong-joon or
whatever said something bad she called
him Jean yang pain or something yeah you
know her manager is like whoa
and all the by that yeah you can't do
that she was I can feel like I'm losing
myself a little bit cuz they're
censoring me she because everybody's
watching yeah she's like which isn't
what I want to do that's the three I'm
saying and I talked to someone high up
super close situation they go we're all
worried about her not that she's gonna
go crazy but we're worried about what
this Fame is gonna do cuz she's because
her naive she's 25 or naive 25 she well
she was Astra
/ she just beat Taylor Swift I'm was one
song in the world she's selling out
arenas all over flying over her
boyfriend is in me goes and it's the
biggest rap you know group in the world
right now so you know they're like we're
worried for her because you know there's
Justin Bieber was 13 came up in this
world but hers is literally overnight I
mean what do you know we don't know how
she's gonna deal with the pressure yeah
yeah man fascinating it's really
fascinating it's really fascinating I
guess all you can keep doing is being
honest but like you said like the
problem with being speaking your mind in
today's world with Twitter where people
can gang up on you anonymously is it's
really hard to not censor yourself it's
really hard yeah you can say something
innocent you know I think a lot of it a
lot of the times the Twitter universe
and everybody has lost their sense of
humor you can't joke around we can't be
sarcastic and Twitter I free can't even
be joke there's a DJ in the same article
do the literally the biggest DJ in the
world I forget his name but there's a
Q&A with him and they're talking about
how used to be like so political and
controversial on social media and stuff
like that and he said it was affecting
the shows just cuz remember people hear
me drop tracks and do this I thought of
you in this sense with you saying how
you know he's political star I'm not an
expert I my opinions and I would put it
out there and I started to see like my
family's like what the [ __ ] is got some
experts yeah and he was started
affecting my music and you know ya
realize kids 1836
they weren't tuning to me for this I
hate to change his glasses approach yeah
it changed to approaches dynamics he's
literally the biggest DJ in the world
it's crazy
Wow and he's saying how like how old
musicians and he referenced Taylor Swift
he goes a lot mostly like young people
can't relate to her what she's thing
about this heartbreak and Hurd life and
being the stars that she is like no one
can relate to that so the music so big
in like these young rappers today you
look at rappers now Ivan I don't know
someone who are you talking to / doing
the same DJ okay you saying the young
rappers now how they're streaming
everything in they're talking about you
know money and drugs like that's what
people that's what they're doing he's
like he's so out of tune with what the
music yeah because as you get older you
start to recognize
trends and patterns that were you and
then you and also as you get older you
start thinking more about kind of the
world you're gonna leave behind so you
get more serious as you get older and
it's really hard to not talk about
things that you're thinking about this
as it which is a byproduct of being
older you're not as silly anymore
because [ __ ] matters more maybe or you
just have a better sense of where
something is going or you're worried
maybe you just worry more I really don't
know that many silly like 56 year old
though right like there's not but not
like like I don't you want to start
saying something you know or at least
and you do you have to be very careful I
think the best way to get people to
think though is also always with humor
you you have if i sat here and would
like parotid like an idea from a book
okay there are some really great ideas
and they're important to get out there
when you start talking the minute you
use the scientist said one word to me he
goes mitochondria he was trying to
explain how a cell how cell breaks down
the human cell and he goes mitochondria
and my brain I went ah science I don't
know anything you don't mind I do but I
was like my brain went he's a scientist
he's talking technically stuff and I and
all of a sudden I stopped listening I
almost voluntarily stopped understanding
cuz he started to use words that were
unfamiliar to me it depends where I'm at
it depends if I'm in a doctor's office
and they're talking about that or Tom
listen a podcast with so news and you
want to learn about that well if I'm
gonna listen to podcasts I know what
it's about and they're an expert in that
field and they start calming commenting
on that yeah I'm in if it's two guys
like us yeah start bringing down I don't
know micro conned reacted cells Matakana
you know what you lose your audience
yeah you know that's not what they're
here for
no they're here dude laughs oh my god
stealing but pushing on with some
experts yeah there's a little legit
expert on yeah yeah yeah that's right
that's how I did this podcast mind pump
if you're in mine pump now say fitness
podcasts and so you're kind of the same
with me you're a little more looser I'm
with this but I don't do a lot of other
podcasts I just don't I'll do if they're
in our circle like Segura Kreischer Tony
Hinchcliffe obviously rogue enjoyed ears
if they're in our circle I'm down there
friends and yeah it's easy if it's
outside that I don't I just don't want
to do it if I'm gonna say someone say to
you I'm here this is where this word
when it's there words exactly
so this mind pump it and it's a fitness
body I'd only want to talk about fitness
you know this so there Booker just kept
hounding the find the kid what non-stop
email and email and email and email and
I'm literally that what you're talking
six months yeah we're checking would you
finally break down and jegos Jesus
Christ they're there in LA for God's
sakes they're there is there any way you
can do it like man I don't want to do it
I just I don't have time I've been so
busy I've worked 7 to 17 days straight
I'm gonna a day off this is the one day
I was gonna you know have a half day I
don't want to do it and Jays like
alright well let me tell him in the lady
goes I understand that she was at rude
she's I understand that they're actually
their Studios gonna be at the pick him
up box burners five minutes away can you
do it then I'm like all right all right
you got to admire that right so I get
there and I get them in my workout
they're there
I Drive down to the studio right off
Main Street right by earth cafe and I'm
like God were and how about Fitness it's
three dudes nice guys and we sit down
and it was complete the complete
opposite they don't in they're like no
right there like gather great they were
great good guys great podcast for mine
pump they did they've done a bunch of
other people but it wasn't about Fitness
at all I don't want to talk about you
know football training and MMA training
the couch guys left they went the exact
opposite great they're great but I just
assumed you know yeah you're the same
well it's not like of course I'm gonna
show you Stewart here I know we're gonna
throw games would you want someone
wearing our family with also like when
they want to talk about the things that
were your job like I actually hate
talking about comedy like III don't talk
to it I don't know yeah I even when they
talk about the great comic system like I
I know that's heavy I don't care I like
to have a conversation the gritty years
want to talk about yeah it's like to
have a con man I had a guy come on to me
after this he started giving me jokes oh
no I'm not getting that serious to his
wife was standing there and he just goes
I don't know them for you I was like oh
man hey listen I gotta go to the dentist
and get some my teeth drilled with no
Novik
but I'd love to sit here and listen to
you sir laughing yeah what's his wife
like come on honey she goes but I just
had to stop I go you tell I'm gonna see
how this works my pictures isn't how
this gives right yeah I go I'm taking
pictures right now and you want to stop
and tell me jokes okay god I don't know
now that's a bummer
probably probably 50 probably 40 47
that's actually always the age what do
you think he was 38 he was like alright
let's do it man you on the road with me
he's probably a guy who's always been
funny right or always wanted to be funny
okay
funny scared the barbecue that's right
and or or no but he's he so he's not the
funniest guy but a lot of times guys
were not that funny will will remember
jokes they're good joke tellers and so
if I remember jokes and then they'll
tell you jokes and that's their way of
getting you to laugh they're not funny
off-the-cuff connected yeah like one of
the things about doing Artie Lange show
was he I always forget what a genius he
is like he is a father always said that
about he's a [ __ ] a lot of people say
that right I am I'm never early genius
yeah I think Artie Lange is like just as
far as a guy who can riff and come up
with amazing things to me I've never
this is my job I've never met anybody
that good amount really I've never seen
anything like it
he's that good he's he is as close to a
genius as I've ever seen in terms of
just one after another after another
after another I'll tell you why he's
amazing I got reference for you you've
seen dirty work with Norm Macdonald in
him yep
yeah he always gives you your money back
he goes did you buy it did you go see it
he was he'll give you 12 bucks because
here's expect I'll give them whatever
money I haven't well my favorite my
favorite things he does he when he's
dead standard because do you saw dirty
work who saw really in your pull my
pocket I [ __ ] love dirty work well and
boat trip yeah I'm a I am a huge fan
he's just his ability to just constantly
be funny he's just a beast I've never
seen a scene like now he was on the
crashing right yeah he's I'm crashing he
was on he's done a lot of stuff he's
always working always working but his
issue has been his drugs I'm not ratting
I'll tell you right now you know what's
out it's out in the public but it's been
drugged
it used to be booze and now it's drugs
you know that's his heroin heroin and
cocaine heroin yeah that doesn't work
out oh there's my money but he's so
funny he's seen a soap what's he do but
does he traveled he's a stand-up comic B
I don't know if he's doing a lot of
stand-up now but as far as one of the
kindest one of the kindest people and
one of the funniest people and I and I
was reminded of a diseased man yeah and
you know we've known each other now 25
years ever so and we were watching clips
of us together
I'm MADtv they're so young yeah what
were you guys doing we did a lot of
sketches together no I'm saying I did
his show I got a show a podcast
all right so ray I think it's a podcast
might be a radio show it's a radio by
both these days yeah yeah it's like a
new he's like on a new New York radio
yeah and he had had stuttering John from
Stern on oh yeah I got in a fight a real
fight yeah yeah stuttering John I didn't
I was there I didn't see it but I guess
stuttering John kind of left in a huff
and they were talking about it I guess
starring John brought up the fact that
Artie's dad fell off a roof and was a
quadriplegic and and but there was no
joke there and then it's just yeah I got
weird I don't know so yeah also our
already comes from a rough background do
you know comes from a great family but
his father when he was 18 was this real
tough roofer and fell off and became
quadriplegic and the only time you know
I'm not emotional right I'm not
emotionally time I've cried I've cried
really hard was the time he told me a
story about when his dad said goodbye to
him when his dad was decided no longer
it you didn't commit suicide
well you know whatever it was his dad
decided that this was not how he want to
live life and I start crying at on
Larchmont Avenue we were eating and I
started to cry and I couldn't help but
cry the way he told the story you know
he's got that gravelly voice and the way
tells a story
and I I was in I embarrassed my were
crying they would have to kick me out if
I were like how to do that dude job get
the [ __ ] you know me I'm very
uncomfortable here in front of our duck
with a moon in front of everybody and I
started to cry like I couldn't stop
crying why was he telling the story I
asked him I asked him not about his dad
I asked him we got into the story after
knowing him for two years
yeah
a beautiful man I love the guy I really
love him man and it was really a treat
to be with it some great stories us he
was on Stern and just a be a basement
I'd love to get my hair fuse he's gonna
be yeah he'll come on he's and he'll
kill you oh you and I just I just go to
New York - yeah I'm always looking for
an excuse to go to New York did you hang
out he'll be he'll be here in January
oh really yeah I already talked all
perfect yeah should do dinner yes he'll
do some dinner and some below see what
happens he loves it he's so open about
awesome he's so open about his struggle
so we're not saying anything on oh yeah
it's interesting if if you don't have
those struggles how like is he one of
the greats
you know III truly believe he is I'm
saying it let's say he didn't have these
holdups with what without a quote
without doubt if you have is is he he's
already already with the drugs already
with that he's already know grace till
Greg you don't say like I wonder what
his potential would've been yeah but
same with sports like with Jon Jones ago
man think what Jon Jones could have done
or think about Mike I screwed up didn't
you go down this road on it yeah I don't
think they're as great as they are if
you make him go down that route see this
is a really interesting question because
sometimes part of what makes already so
it's it's so amazing is the chaos that
the chaos and the self-loathing and the
sort of the lot of times great comedians
have a great deal of shame self-loathing
and all those things and that that
brings out amazing comedy it also brings
out self-destructive behavior so it goes
hand-in-hand so I don't know how do you
take one element out of somebody that
makes him great you know it's really
hard to but he's a beautiful dude man I
love
he is aging like a pier in the Sun
though like a pear in the Sun the good
drugs do that man yeah yeah my buddy one
time said that my buddy goes nobody did
a lot of nobody had a lot of problems
and then did a lot of blow and a lot of
heroin and then when you know what
things are better now you know if this
is wait a minute now I got some real
problems here I listen I need about a
year and back I'm gonna do I'm sniffing
bunch of cocaine and heroin I'll be back
a little bit but I get to pistol bad
guys let's go P let's go P hard beyond I
want to tell you I was watching this
show
will uncomfortable watch oh and Joe I
forget what it's called it's on the Wii
network or some [ __ ] like that
on the week but it's like Celebrity
Rehab but four couples and it's coupled
up for horrible issues it's drug issues
are no it's reality couples who are on
they're not drug issues they just say if
the horrible really [ __ ] problems I cut
the tail end of and I just watch it
because two people are fighting like
I'll watch that for a second and they
were doing this exercise and these are
two you know expert professional
relationship expert so they have the
couples come up there and they talk
about I you tell me if you do this with
your girls like there's no [ __ ] way
I'd ever do that
they say describe and so let me lay this
out it's an exercise where you have to
basically like dolls that look like look
like you so one so let's say we're gay
as [ __ ] we're in a relationship you know
the doll it looks like you I have dog
looks like me and you act out whatever
you're going through right it's
ridiculous what they say when you act it
out you you don't you're not
self-conscious because you're you're on
the outside looking in or something yeah
there you go
so they're doing that and they ask the
girls in the guy they go now describe
best sex you've had outside of your
partner whoa and I was like damn that's
that's getting deep I feel I feel like
that's a bet in it didn't go well like
the couples that didn't know they got
all of them far that well as soon as
they're like thank you that's the
exercise for may have a good time for
the rest of the night they were just
like thank ya cuz one girl so this is
hilarious that's the girl and she's like
it was uh it was before I met whatever
the [ __ ] the homeboys name is and it was
in the water and this guy got behind me
and basically [ __ ] me in the water and
you can see her man's like she's like
and then they go whatever his name as
they go Ryan's you're turning us my turn
you can tell he's like pissed off you
might drink cool he goes up to another
to another girl's daughters can I have
this yeah he grabs two female dolls
tossed him in the bed puts himself in
the middle she goes what the [ __ ] he is
here's a threesome and did you like why
yes best sex ever had it was a threesome
ended with two girls oh not one - cuz
now he's one up oh my god is so fun I
wanna
because you can tell you're just waiting
for his turning ism my turn coal on I
see you doll and the girls like sure
dude all for the best but I was like God
I looked at John like this is a terrible
actress horrible exercise terrible no no
you don't wanna do that and then one
they had they had with that so the girl
cheated on her man they've [ __ ] like
they have trust issues and like best sex
she's like I don't want to do this and
they're like well it's part of the like
you got to do it she's like alright well
like the other week I was cooking and
you know the guy came up behind me and
then she grabbed the doll and they bent
the female doll and put the male one
behind it was like this and you can see
the man she's with like he didn't go
he's just so emotionally wrapped he
didn't go I'm like I feel like this is
terrible advice I think it's terrible I
feel like some things that you just
shouldn't really yeah you should exhaie
how about a little mystery man and
talking about exes is a bad idea it's
like man these are two experts I
remember I saw a picture of this girl is
dating and she I see up there I go who's
that guy was [ __ ] dude who's that guy
and it was a dude it was a picture of it
was a polo add basically of a guy
standing next to a crew boat you know a
skull you know the kind of yeah yeah and
he had hair he had hair like yours like
a Great Gatsby here and he was every bit
of six five or bread and Thoreau picking
down a girl crazy and I go I'm who what
is that cuz I thought it was at an ad or
something she goes oh that's my old
boyfriend Joe is about six four she goes
six six I go 6x because yeah he was at
an Olympia he was a bet even have a big
dick Amazon is so of course of course
you know me
I said up now was he a crow road crew
she goes yeah he was an Olympic
alternate actually I go oh so a hell of
an athlete a hell of an athlete big
hands I go let me ask you this
you have a dick on knowing of course
that he did she goes it was very
proportional I went of course of course
it was hey it's all good I white old you
I've told it years gone podcast that
girls dating forever
trying to make it work this is years and
years ago not even close and she came up
she was in another state came here and
she left her iPad unlocked
I thought email said xxx I remember
we're trying to work things out you ran
this I told you the next day
hammer it very well hard to see I'm no
one else knows this I mean I'll see all
our fans so no one else close to me
knows this yeah I'm like she was
sleeping she came in she was exhausted
we haven't seen each other in forever
trying to make things work I see her
iPad actually thinking about maybe kind
of you know like real deal yeah maybe
like kind of really love it we have to
give this out yet
like maybe you move her in maybe you
give this a shot maybe this is the one
maybe after all this time we really make
it a make a go for it are ya all right
she's all this leaves his first night
iPads out and I'm like I you know I
don't really [ __ ] with electronics I
don't want to work more when I'm home
like iPads are cool never had one let me
scroll through it so I hit interest on
lock that you know just hit it and I hit
it and her emails open like I got to him
her emails open I didn't know how to
mess it but then you know just curious
George her I'm like yeah it's very clear
it says xxx pics I'm like [ __ ] is that
like a porno or something I gotta see
that I'm like there's not a man in the
world way woman in the world that would
does an answer that's consent click
click oh that's consent where I come
from in Denver it's like the old
clickety click oh no no there's some
stuff that will be forever burned into
your memory they're just both so they're
the old Brazilian homies running a train
on your girl will [ __ ] your day up
that's right that's right I mean granted
we were separate not talking I was like
click good good-looking fella whoa
good-looking fellow with a piece on ah
good looking fellers good-looking
sellers okay so now I'm why am i a
little turned on right now
yeah me too a little bit I mean but so
the net so what I mean it's a lot all
your time I broke it I mean your heart
goes oh and I'm like oh well no this is
over thank you big man upstairs cuz
that's as clear as day as in in this
thing yeah so then I'm like oh she needs
a rest so I'm just gonna sit here I
normally get some sleep you know I'm
just going to get some sleep I'm up all
night like this of course you are at
suit at 6:00 a.m. you know chuny's goes
times 6 and she's like what times like
hey I didn't sleep
I'm like I cannot wait no I just like oh
like soap righteous no I mean I saw you
next day uh-huh next morning like what
have Mythili you look shell-shocked it's
just you don't know you don't expect
that now that's that's that's a hard one
they say they say in relationships the
most important this guy Gottman who
studied all these relationships and like
videotaped couples having arguments and
then would follow them throughout their
Kurt their relationships said the most
important thing in making a relationship
work is learning how to fight meaning
you never you never use contempt you
never call each other a name you can
complain right so you can say you know I
asked you to take out the trash four
times but you're on the same team yeah
it's not cool but when you say it's just
like you to be a selfish prick
no that causes that is always he always
would always predict he'd be like the
new right Oh Angus it's not gonna last
and never like he's actually talked
about that her when you every couple
fights but you're you're at least on the
same team yeah like you're fighting for
a reason but you're on the same team yes
you don't insult each other that's right
add another X what we were talking about
things and she's talking about her
ex-boyfriend and you know saying you
know we joke around like big dicks just
oh god I'm like yes tiny dick feels too
big she was too big
she was discussing I went yeah that's
just know where she goes oh god you bet
you could do anything with that like all
right well this is not gonna work out
but she kept doing [ __ ] and you could
like she was scarred like she finally
saw the Loch Ness monster she's like oh
god and I'm like yes tiny dick she goes
too big so here's what I think every
time I get I to me I'd swear that I'd be
a problem huh
now this is what I do I go Wow too big
so the first 9 inches was amazing the
first 9 inches I would guess it was the
3 inches after that but you had trouble
with like obviously while number one you
dated him for two years so if it wasn't
that bad I pretend I perked up what you
went all it to tiny day like micro mini
oh just to Bailey mmm well that's
problem yeah let's bring guess we'll
just go our separate ways now yeah dick
size matters - guys we care yes and no I
don't care yeah well you know you just
don't want
you know when I don't really care it's
just incident talk about its when it's
like when she's describing and it sounds
like it has lungs that's an issue like
what do you mean that don't make that
noise when a girl goes oh it's like
Jesus I mean it's it that deserves a
sound effect ah I said he doing
different in my mind yeah I think she's
gonna say ah tubing yeah well like your
dick if I had a sound effect people my
dick is you know and his is ah so
they're different in a different loves
love's love's to this game that's always
no mine's like you're like no my big guy
big guy and then me regular guy you know
and then that guy yeah yours is more
like oh like I old the things still
there hey man Rumpy don't say boom you
got frumpy dick well one is to do your
[ __ ] your David I got old pillowcase
like you as a child you've had that
pillow it might have gone through
college from you can't it it's just like
it's like all the stuffing let's say
it's a feathered pillow yeah it's all
just down yeah like it's all wrinkly at
the top and it's there don't get me
wrong
you have a dick guy I got a dick on me
but I didn't like it he was like it's
over yeah I'm not talking about his nuts
I'm talking about your dish yeah it's
like he looks like he's in a bad mood
kind of like arms folded slumped in a
chair kind of an old guy no it looks
like gonzo sleeping taking a nap and
he's just fully relaxed and it's just
there yeah
like everything's relaxed yeah just
think of gonzo unlike percocet yeah
that's what your [ __ ] just a big
from yeah like there's not like you're
not scared of it but you're not that's
what I like to do to my wife when she's
in a bad mood and I like to I'm sitting
there and I just appeal it out just a
big heavy sad piece and I go does this
make you feel better playing like no it
doesn't it's disgusting
you're disgusting you're like I kept
doing redness of your balls ain't fun
either let's be honest yeah I don't know
how red there
look those red is this chair no my boss
yeah like what they're like a dark red
how many like a bone well they're
they're they're abuse you read the
British Browns oh yeah yeah fire hydrant
balls
MJ wasn't here I would
can't do that yesterday me too I would
matter which screaming she would follow
sensual suit against you so fast pulled
your dick Erina yeah I don't do that I
call variety okay by the way but that's
something I don't do this thing I've
ever done
hey I don't know yeah yeah like you were
telling about that you just pull out
like what you're doing yeah shut up -
you're lazy piece piece that's not lazy
you know he's content yeah maybe he's
been through so much war he looks like
an old scallywag seeing some [ __ ] like
you seen some [ __ ] yeah he's more like I
listen yeah I did there are no that's
words I'm like those are barnacles
[ __ ] you dicks the toughest guy
in the bar when he's not gonna tell you
a lot of war stories really gonna flex
up on you he's been through it he's like
that old great white that you catch like
Jesus Christ sees bigs not that
aggressive got an eye patch on us maybe
but his nose is all [ __ ] up yep got a
broken nose that's your dick yeah it's
always running sorry
look maybe I should get that checked out
I don't know do some commits wait what'd
you guys do this weekend sure what'd you
do speaking of Wow fishing fishing we're
at several would like it sounds like a
lot of people moving there right
Silverwood Lake would you go fishing
with I'm ready Lewis great question just
you and your buddy Lewis did you guys
camp no it was that day it was that day
we had Deonte here so I came back from
all 200 fish over and opened fire if we
had enough time you guitar out and like
sing about the fish question toss on
guitar guitar I don't know where you're
going with this bill I'm just sayin him
and his French fishing caught a fish oh
wow check out the wild fish
let's skin it sleep here yeah eat the
fish yeah let me season the fish now
yeah you know what I mean no only one
sleeping bag these rulers watch doors
are my shorts are wet do you mind if I
change into something a little more
comfy like this loincloth loincloth oh
there we go
better build a fire for jelly are you
chilly huh can you sit next to me
because I don't have my blanket standard
camping hey you got a taste a bite of
this hey girl let me whoops let's taste
of I let me let me cover the fork so it
doesn't spill open slowly open there you
go
how good is
it's a nice take your time take your
time and let the juice what's on miso
dressing on there I'd love some miso
dressing yeah
can I sing you a song you know this
thing I'd be nice you are I sing western
country western a lot of other stuff oh
wow well but I'm not doing a fighter in
a kid is there a bowl of wine sure is I
brought wait why is there a bottle of
wine in your guitar case well you know
what and here's the thing I can't drink
too much I'm Korean so I get very very
red I don't have the enzymes to break
down so I'm just gonna drink it that's
exactly right
all right get you apply it up a little I
mean why don't we get you a relaxed and
have yourself a glass of wine there you
go you want to do a little too little
sweet no do it wait I don't do coke
people experience stuff is real coke
fish and wine you know what I do I cut
it with my hey bro hey bro coke fishing
wine try [ __ ] I'm not doing anything of
the sort
what are you doing why are you pointing
a finger at me you got one finger
pointing at me but I see three fingers
pointed at you you okay we're just
trying to [ __ ] you can't take it head
one finger that's all I'm saying
that's on saying Weinstein watch it's
all it is see you ain't campus I just so
you were fishing all day and then drove
here from the Deontay Wilder interview
yeah and then went back out there to the
man's done oh you're early
how early seven o'clock they open up
[ __ ] did you catch a bunch of fish zero
fish not fishers there's nothing up
there you guys just can't fish I think
we just don't you're not good at fishing
yeah fishing is got a tone technique and
sometimes I catch fish but what where
were you guys this is fishermen talk to
together yeah I got nothing what you
guys use for your lures cast masters
did you drive metal they don't brought
those are the lawyers but then we use
night crawlers as bait Oh see the night
crawlers a getcha daily a bite on the
night crawler nothing zero night
crawlers if you tried hot at all
expensive night crawlers you tried hot
dogs or earthworms you ever trying or
Nightcrawler that girls like Bigfoot
that one's huge
oh sorry come on hey come on every man
why hey come on oh dude you're such a
city boy come on man oh no I finally
brought you guys we were saying chin
icon loosing world let it come camping
with you guys I'll cook yeah you guys
guys I'll be your blanket keeper beers
warm
I'll keep you date your beers warm hey
bro I said beers I'll keep you warm you
do it Indian rug burn on a dick ah sure
let's go no let's play Indian burn on
your dick let's sit on a hand jump hey
uh you didn't catch any fish no fish
little fun it's just you know I the
problem I bet your problems you guys are
too chatty too loud it's a problem with
fishers that's interesting you know if
you like scared the fish no no you don't
talk hmm
I put my headphones in and go to work on
them fish and you a good fisherman yeah
I grew up fishing you can hook it really
grew up fishing will skip grew up
fishing non-stop right with uncle si
uncle skin I just get that uncle skin
there for 15 years was he a real uncle
or just that neighbor over there I took
a real liking da man I'll skip bro all
right made my ETSU okay cool
easy bro hip and Su veteran bro skip
veteran bro I'm out of fish just skip on
dropping some knowledge on Jin over here
see the heart of Conda educate you guys
let me see the first guy to introduce
you to alcohol when you're a young buck
that is no you mentioned I thought yeah
put some sunblock on the shoulders here
and go ahead and have another beer yeah
that's wrong that was about 39 by honey
yeah we'd do that mm-hmm don't know that
you want to talk
sure man what do you want talk about
okay I was fine I just you know I would
have my shirt off and I would cast out
there and drink bears and play some
music and then oh all right
that's you know how's Kevin Spacey doing
they mention it yeah no they're for
China all right don't you the thing live
world all right we're in a very it with
a weird spot yeah so you didn't catch
any fish came back then
do that I mean what the [ __ ] did you do
with the rest of your free time Jim
Friday Saturday Sunday I am dying to
know I feel like we should hire an
investigator follow him around yeah
ready
you know man just yeah you got a strong
case i'm yuneisia every time oh we have
weird some guy talking [ __ ] to us he
goes how the [ __ ] does cred not know
about this chicken place in Koreatown
this is the best fried chicken in the
world it's in LA Koreatown
I'll be bare I forget he sent me da met
you it's over you bear it's delicious
fried chicken now we need to go there
I'll be back we got a post mate so I'll
be back
yeah because the problem is Koreatown
takes a long time to get to for some
reason it's so packed and crowded there
I'm Jay how's your house torian's with
Korean yeah just okay yeah would you do
em Jake yelling that mic chin just dying
for us to get off him we have no idea
what the [ __ ] you know what cares my
life so uninteresting until the semester
ends I totally signed up for way too
many units how many how many classes you
take in 15 units I'm taking what you
like to mean these okay so
units like the amount of hours that you
put into the classes showing what you
put into it so I'm doing over a
full-time schedule so why did you do
that
because I signed up for all these
classes before I got the internship here
and I didn't want to drop the class so
cuz I had one class that started in
October it's I got a hybrid or like
condensed class so I'm kind of just so
you're burning the camera both ends
right now yeah put the fire in the
cooler what wow it's gonna be like no
I'm just saying okay I'm just saying it
comes down and listen I love the fine
kid but it comes down the 5 you're
kidding your education
I'd go with getting your degree call me
crazy ok get the old degree yeah I'm do
not working and then moving some packing
up my stuff you're trying to move it did
you find a place I'm like in between
right now oh cool give on your address
where you know right
cuz that won't be creepier I'm putting
into storage right now and so then get
all these guys are all is that it MJ
tell her she's hot alright I'll make
sure I tell her that thank you so much
underscore cheeto fingers 69 9 says
you're hot and he'd like to take yeah
yeah what about
bro I'm pretty pissed the chin didn't
take me fishing because I've made it
pretty clear that I going to go fishing
I agree I think that's pretty much yeah
you did say you won't go fish in there
she said she couldn't go that day she
thought was like you think you loo that
and then you so went the day I couldn't
go hey she said she wants to go fishing
with the whole crew would you guys go
sit in the boat behind why I wouldn't
know you're on a boat bro not deep-sea
fishing you try to stay p.m. go deep-sea
fishing I'll do it I just get that with
any good for you oh I've done it you
can't you can't get on a boat no I can't
you housecat I'm not I get seasick
easily you take pills or that I know we
would ginger we went we went whale
watching with my daughter's elementary
school back in the day like God they
come with a razor blade
oh my well no I knew you were watching
so I said to my wife I said like a
couple things you need to know we're
going out there it's a beautiful day
great day for whale watching I said
understand something you're gonna get
seasick so let's go ahead and take some
Dramamine number one number two let's go
ahead and bring em all three layers of
clothing I was gonna go with Molly
Molly's not a good idea three layers of
clothing and I get on there and cuz I
know when you're out and see oh it gets
cold it gets cold to matter timely and
you're gonna get sick so we get out
there and all of a sudden were looking
for whales and the whole the schools
there now the teachers and the parents
came out in short sleeves and yep
amateurs the temperature of course you
ought to see the wind starts blowing and
it drops and it drops and I mean it's
like it turns into a nice day into a
nightmare well because the wind is a
blown we're talking about the sea the
sea give a [ __ ] about your fourth-grade
dynamic they don't give a [ __ ] timeout
mother nature hidin does not care put
the god sea Poseidon Poseidon is like
you just try to [ __ ] he starts and
blowing it's almost whales
oh no this ain't Nemo kids those whales
are mean as [ __ ] they get into the ship
well we saw we saw some seals we saw
dolphins and then we saw a giant whale
but but what kind of whale we talk
believe it was a great way the hump
Packard gray believed it was a gray but
it might have been a humpback but it was
one of the other you know if you saw
humpback wasn't yeah either way what I
know is this we saw the whale but
everybody with the exception of me my
family were not only too cold to even go
outside they mr. Winnick is [ __ ] they
were all your whole family got sick no
no because I remember buddy took like my
kids were wearing the the patches and I
anyway either way we were all fine you
you you're made by water for the waspey
and you died through the water I was
worried you're in a knit by a great
white cuz you look so much like a seal
you're brown you're smooth and you're
about the size of a big bull seal and
you were that you were just you were
like you're you're so water like you're
made for water because you were in and
you were coming out at the feet we're
all together yes yeah your body was all
like undulating I was like a pro you are
looking to lower than the lawn you look
delicious to a grot wat so for God's
left leg to grab on it glad that's the
scientific term for great white and I
was like you've got to stop doing that
like the bane of the water
it was amazing you're you were almost
barking uh-uh-uh and you would go under
I was like is that a steel or brenden I
do love it and you had your head shaved
I feel it's crazy a little whiskers you
love the oh man oh man
yeah ocean is obvi took my shorts off
this year but oh do you guys go though
so much I live a block commotion so
lucky you don't go never heard you runs
or something if I did I do
why my knees [ __ ] doesn't tell me not to
run the sand right did say never
yeah it depends what you're going for it
can be good your size you need to you
can run it someone like me needs around
the same cuz my knees but I think run
the sand is good do and I think Lauren
land I would back this hypothesis up
doing it like once every two weeks would
be good but if you're a professional
athlete and you're trying to be
explosive the scene actually takes all
that away because it just there's no
there's no recoil there's no you don't
off the ground there's this you know on
the whole in Santa takes on that in
right Wow you can get yourself tired
don't work in the same it must be why
I'm not as explosive as I could row up
in the sand around yeah
the sand glove training and this helped
the beach man does that seem not moving
Tarzana
that lasted I'll hold on for hours I
drove out there well I told you the
realtor was like oh you'd have to leave
your studio Tarzana and I'm like well no
my students in Playa Vista and he was
like oh no no no what
there's no way you're going back for now
and then and then we got I think when I
get done with the wilder podcasts at
like 6 o'clock at night and so just I
was like you know what let me just Mack
questell anything we get from the studio
to this house I'm thinking about Oh two
hours in 15 minutes and I'm out I check
somewhat hey I'm out I'm out
I'd miss everything I miss my kid
missing the worst yeah the most yeah
something is off the map you cannot do
it no I'll tell you what I watched that
documentary on Netflix Andy and how was
it it's good yeah crazy crazy really
nuts nuts he really went all the way
went all the way they even had Andy's
family there like sister like it's it's
insane like it's like talking to Andy I
just the character to play and Universal
didn't want the footage released because
they said you'd come off like an [ __ ]
which I guess but they're worried it
affect what's he talking about it now
Jim Carrey yeah you got a little crazy
president what do you think I don't know
I don't think everyone's like no he's
crazy and that people don't know jisu I
did to his ex-girlfriend she commits
suicide listen I don't get involved in
that stuff I don't like him for that
stuff I don't give a [ __ ] what TMZ in
this personal life is I'm saying I like
him for his body of work yeah what he's
done it's his story was crazy how he
wrote himself a check when I first came
to LA ro himself a ten million dollar
check like you know you envisioned it
you can put it down himself ten million
dollar check I think he said three or
five years later since wrote that check
he got tenth he had ten million dollar
check because he did Ace Ventura Dumb
and Dumber and the mask in the same year
he had ten valve see ten million dollars
well his father passed away cuz he said
his dad so he's the funniest guy in the
world that's where he got all was funny
for now but his and his father was a
musician and his father always wanted to
be the star and he was in Canada but
didn't it paid the bill so he became an
accountant kind of
put a chip on the shoulder so then Jim
was like I was kind of doing it for him
I want to show him like you know what
you couldn't do it so I'm gonna do it
and he goes in finally you know I wrote
myself the stimulant dollar check and I
get ten million dollars my dad right
before the mask came out was the hit
that it is he passed away so as they're
bearing his dad he slipped that ten
million dollar check in his dad's pocket
as they buried him it's a crazy story
yeah phenomenal story Wow yeah but they
showed Jim at the Comedy Store which I'm
at The Comedy Store at night and I saw
him it's the same stage you know the
main stage like oh [ __ ] that's Jim Tyler
he was a room for you all the time but
when I see it I like all that stuff
makes me so nervous I was like oh my god
that's where I'm at yeah good as it gets
I remember watching him you know people
say he's crazy I think I'd like you your
opinion on it because you watching he
goes they go he goes I know Andy as well
as I can know like as far as not being
him I know him better than anyone that
isn't him I studied everything met with
his family former girlfriend everything
wife kid like I'm as not kids but as far
as anyone know I got as close as you can
get to him without being him and then he
goes but as in act and entertainment how
well do you really know yourself like
being like you're constantly playing
this other person this musician he's
like how how even when you meet some how
well do you really know yeah I can see
how people you know he's crazy or this
that I know he has his weird stuff on
YouTube but a lot of it makes sense
yeah I think what what I think is I
think he's a guy who's experienced a lot
get to the top of the mountain and then
now he's just he's still creative as
[ __ ] and he's just you know he's just
kind of looking back and everything and
I think the world in entertainment that
we live in and especially to his degree
it's such a mindfuck he's trying to
unravel everything now cuz he's yeah I
think he's a guy first of all I remember
watching him a nice Ventura and I'm are
watching him in living color and I used
to only watch and let me cover it for
him and I would wait and I remember
being so astonished at how good he was
like I don't care what anybody says and
it was really fashionable when I was on
MADtv it was really fashionable forever
in the comedy world to hate Jim Carrey
why because he was obvious because he
was not cool almost so it so aids mnsure
like I remember like what would you as
he watched Jim Carrey or have slow
dental surgery and I remember that and
there that way it was fashionable to
hate on Jim Carrey's because people hate
it and I was like okay you were never
gone well I must be missing it because
to me this guy is a [ __ ] genius
and I saw that movie in the movie
theater Ace Ventura the first one and
nobody knew he was I mean they knew for
him from in living color but the
laughter in that and I was like it's
hard to astonish me I was so [ __ ]
astonished at everything that guy was
doing oh my god and then he then then he
did the mask and and if you go back to
see how good he was in the mask as well
his ability to not only be to do
impressions but also to just be
originally hilari you know he would get
up at the company store not write
anything just get up because I just try
and feel things out and he said he had a
breakthrough when he came up there and
didn't care what the audience he was
like I'm just kidding I'm gonna do what
I want to do I could you got standing
ovations for his impressions well no
he's a guy doing press till he went up
there's doing this thing and he goes
how's everyone doing for they can she
was all righty then and there just slams
the mic he goes it was a breakthrough
for me cuz I don't get I'm not doing for
them I'm sad I'm doing what I want to do
exactly he needs like in the establish
the relationship like yeah I'm here to
entertain you there's a reason why
you're here here's how it's gonna go
it came from how you guys doing tonight
before they could answer is all right he
did to think of it so and you know I
think he's a guy who did literally got
to the top of the mountain like you said
had all the money in the world and then
because he's such a creative guy and and
probably that's where he gets the meat
of his existence I think he was like all
this stuff is one big distraction and he
probably had a bit of a crisis that
Christ is of being at the top of the
mountain and feeling the same or not
feeling what you thought you were gonna
feel and then kind of going this this
may be the I promise attachment maybe
the problems materialism maybe the
problem he's crazy
he's just searching I think my fans
reach out and I don't look up to him too
much have you seen his personal life
what he did with his axe where you know
he took me made her commit suicide he
didn't I looked into am I
first of all you know the girls like you
know before I make your hide confident
and you introduced me to cocaine and
hookers in time had a good time and this
and then she goes in you belittled me
and now I'm committing suicide yeah
first of all I'm sure she had prior
issues before she met Jim Keshe sure
that's what Jim says Jim goes she was a
tortured soul yeah we had a relationship
this did it help her no but I sure as
[ __ ] didn't she I didn't help her commit
suicide no that's not that's a that's a
much sure I've been looking for a reason
deeper issues like you would and then
you gave her herpes all right herpes
terrible it's the gift that keeps on
currently he did apparently she faked
her medical records to do you know that
that's the new stuff that came out so
that's not that's not that's not proof
so when fan sent me stuff like it so
when the diems I went listen bro your
base and these accusations off the TMZ
order yeah that doesn't work for me yeah
I said do you know someone in Jim's camp
do you know someone's in this girl's
camp yeah unless you base it off what
you get from TMZ or yeah that doesn't
that's not real man yeah you can't you
can't justify that Jim's a bad person
because of this one side story where the
family's so upset that third daughter
commits suicide of course they want to
point the finger at Jim Carrey I'm
guaranteeing she had huge issues before
started doing Jefferson you don't commit
suicide someone gives you herpes and you
made you do cocaine there it's it make
there is a shitload of fake news out
there really is it's it's amazing to me
a fake news show you do some tournaments
do some current events how many should
you happy Thanksgiving fine never zero
good friends zero of my real friends
will text me happy holidays or Happy
Thanksgiving
I'm gonna have zero for like real
friends they know better and I know
better you are scaring birthday yes yeah
Christmas thanks I'm with my family
listen bro I'm out of here
Happy New Year thank you lose the word
holiday I sound like a BA humbug but
[ __ ] it I like it
well first I guess you mean you need a
reason to get together to have a meal
with your family I do that all the time
yeah I don't need I don't need a dry
bird
that turkey sucks balls Oh brode
deep-fried [ __ ] you tastes exactly same
but the crust is harder yeah [ __ ] Turkey
I'll [ __ ] you Turkey
oh man what a terrible bird - you ever
seen one those things yeah you're deep
frying a pterodactyl those things are 80
yes and huge size of this chair
they're giant I'll tell you what I do
like about Thanksgiving I'm off my diet
to Friday you are I've been off my diet
now for a few days when I say ask my dad
it's not that I'm going crazy but like i
din er did a double date with Todd and
his wife no and I just I dessert and I
ordered pasta and what we usually win it
so when I see crazy I'm just wearing
what the [ __ ] I feel like dessert until
Friday then Friday I'm getting for real
we're gonna have a little pie tonight
okay little pie you've earned it we
should go to dressier net me high done
nothing but I feel burned it we talked
we talked to each other I was in New
York you have good food do you know that
that best restaurant I've been to no oh
man which one you know read restaurant
yes you didn't go I did but we're all
going to go promise it's hard to get a
table well but don't we know that
someone knows the guy of the guy of the
friend oh wait yeah you know what you
could have got a table you're just
making promise Lee should have done that
was [ __ ] amazing
you're not by now I want pie no I'm
saying gonna play on Thursday I'm gonna
have pie on Thursday pumpkin or pecan
both yeah both until experience yeah
I'll keep eating turkey I like a nice
cranberry sauce myself my mother makes
an old-fashioned stuffing with acorns
everyone's mom does that's what everyone
says he's corny everyone says that
Laurens in sausage she makes the best
yeah of course she does she makes the
best the best stuff of all time yep
everyone's mom says no I'm but my mom's
better than I know my mom's everyone
more not my mom don't make stuffing no
so my mom we can't cook if you have a
mom out there and she's really good of
stuffing I'm not trying to be a dick my
mom's much better than your mom yeah I'm
not trying to be a dick it off but look
at me in the eye yeah [ __ ] your mom stop
it Hey
excuse no one says that right like I
know paint scheme can be a bore my mom's
stuff is always the stuff stuffing it's
all the [ __ ] saves the other
seasoning bra here's the top it up ready
gravy
dude have you been to lucky Luke's no
okay all right
the best pizza you've ever let's New
York everybody has that's New York like
I know you're from New York but this
pizza in Wisconsin at lucky no all right
that's Pizza Julie the takeaway go [ __ ]
yourself that's correct
beat dry beat and Julia takeaway that's
correct that pie comes out hot it's eat
that piece of pizza it's stupid I pinned
in New York Ben all right
Ivan post picture oh this pizzas I've
been there I've been all over yeah me
too you be a fresh margarita slice of
pie from ydt a what from alpha watering
right burrata you trying to go there
I'll go there in a [ __ ] slap pipe I
get a burr up we're checking both box
I'm eatin [ __ ] pie and and and burrata
margarita and the gay guy cross street
Jeff which one the sunglass hut oh no
Warby Parker you mean yes yeah let's go
over there get you some glasses a
dicksuck two slices of pie I don't want
that part of it I don't need glasses or
a dick sack over there bro I thought we
were I never I never so no we get you
otherwise I feel no I never I didn't did
not come to bro if you want a piece of
pepperoni I'm good good good pizza
yeah some pumpkin pie ah yes yes cool
sunglasses would work actually could you
had a dick so they seed I don't know
where who I was gonna do that Gary no no
over at war before I don't feel
comfortable with that
all right men he has a mustache all
right well it's all or nothing no I
don't want no no pie all right what else
you got chin Charles Manson died hey hey
for sure don't stop my viewing pleasure
with breaking news
I was watching the goddamn AMAs it's all
baby there's a phenomenal performance
going on they stop it mute that the baby
baby baby baby tickets one Charles
Manson tiles I don't give a [ __ ]
Shannon Tate New Roman Polanski's wife
how crazy is that why is this major news
well why would he stop the oil
because he was the first cult leader and
he captured the world's imagination
first of all a celebrity was killed
Sharon Shannon tape or Sharon Tate shot
and killed in a very horrible way and
remember I believe she was seven months
pregnant but he didn't do it is not
Oliver he had his followers to it he was
very good at finding people who were
broken yes and how many how many murders
was at nine were nine seven I thought
she was killed eight and a half months
pregnant she was killed with other
people that's were at home in Benedict
Canyon in the Rope pigs any Hills yeah
it was such a horrific crime and he's
trying to start a race war I guess yeah
it was called helter skelter yeah and he
thought the Beatle song was helter
skelter was played they wrote it for him
yeah like crazy yeah
and he don't he'd been in and out of all
kinds of juvie he called them the
hallways of always and Southern Cal men
he's a very charismatic guy but he was
he also ushered in the idea of a cult
and the hippy and hippies madness and
reformat it was all the stuff that he's
also a musician yeah he was the
personification of evil and so the
American public people were buying guns
and and guard dogs but there were two
sets of murders weren't there I believe
I know nothing about this guy you don't
know [ __ ] hey Chen what you don't know
[ __ ] about Meili man I mean Charles
Manson you know now I have Jane's young
enough where you probably don't know
much about him right this is 1969 I was
two years old the number one thing I
know he has that swastika on his
forehead
that's pretty much yeah women too like
there was a sex thing and a frenzy of
bloodshed but the three girls were just
around raizy man yeah it was this place
in Topanga Canyon yeah I was in Benedict
Canyon
where's that uh so that's in Hollywood
that's that's basically it's basically
Beverly Hills in a really nice house so
shooting stabbing beating and hanging
that fur is raised for others Mouse yeah
but he but his his cult was in I thought
around Topanga and I it probably was and
they wrote pig and blood remember these
were very wealthy people came from
really well-to-do families too and these
were these hippie sort of cult figures
and it was the
it was like oh my god the Communists are
taking over there was all constrast
order race war they wanted to make it to
look like the work of black militants to
start a race war that's right half dozen
followers drove to Los Angeles house he
appeared to have selected at random
inside mr. Manson tied up the residence
a wealthy grocer named Leona LaBianca
and his wife Rosemary before leaving
after he's gone several family members
stabbed a couple to death the phrases
death to pigs and helter skelter
misspelled word scrawled and blood on
the wall the seven murders went unsolved
for months yeah they thought it was at
the serial killer then in the autumn of
1969 the silly seven murders first
unsolved for months then 1969 the police
closed in on the Manson family after
miss Atkins in jail on an unrelated
murder she bragged about it wow what a
terrible person
yeah you got imagine a guy like that
ain't goin to the pearly gate but the
trial was crazy he had an ex carved in
his forehead like watch like that no it
was actually an X Oh was it yeah they
turned into swatch that was an X no no
he might have turned it into it I don't
think ya later carve the X into a
swastika that's what he did that's it
yeah yeah and he always had it in it so
he turned it into a swastika later on
hmm it started as an X I played him in a
sketch on MADtv bring up bring up bring
this sketch up you might please bring it
up yeah I also play Jim Carrey on a
sketch you ever see that I'm MADtv you
play the which one I played him as an
Ace Ventura guy really yeah do they have
all this on uh hopefully talking about
it probably go to youtube chin it'll pop
up if it's here relieve me if you type
in YouTube MADtv Bryan Callen let's try
it
I had to watch tape of it Orlando Jones
Fear Factor oh there's MADtv he's been
sure let's see that so bad rewind it hi
I'm Jim Carrey megastar and media
darling
20 million dollars for my last movie and
it wasn't because of any method training
or phony but no it's because I know what
the public want and now you too can
learn the secrets of my success at the
new Jim Carrey School of Acting well you
guys are making fun of us hey that was
good that was good remember though it's
a wind-up a punch and a reverberation Oh
alrighty then
the karriesue that you saw it he said it
was funny foundation yes you will study
the magic behind me unique and startled
to so exhaustive efforts here's Jim in
Ace Ventura oh right he then here's Jim
and dumb and dumber
oh right he then here's Jim in Batman
Forever you'll learn how to contort your
face like a palsy victim talk through
different human orifices and apply these
same techniques to roll after roll after
roll no matter what the parts actually
call for and just wait'll you see that
before I attended the Jim Carey School
of Acting our city birthdays but now I
know what real acting means smoking
forget Stanislavski say sayonara says
them some people may prefer a range in
artistry but they aren't the ones seeing
my movies oh and there is one more thing
maybe if Olivier had learned how to talk
out of his ass he would have made twenty
million dollars too
[Music]
stop me
so how old were you I was 28 God there
is there not the you ever see that you
ever see that one I've seen that work
where's the we've done that one on his
they're not the the Charles Manson I
though mine there should be that's so
weird the regular and then you find it
I'm surprised MADtv doesn't have their
own channel yeah they would give us
tapes and back then you'd have to watch
tapes you were doing and they're good we
don't want to [ __ ] okay it's not crazy
thank god he's dead for sure don't stop
my show that gets important yeah see
what else we get what else you got
jin-yi oh this one yeah for sure
during discussion about guns insurance
man actually she cries a guy shot his
wife accidentally in a church killed her
there no no no they're both fine but
when they're talking about that you know
that recent church killing in Texas yeah
yeah that guy told his uh his friends at
church he's like that's why I always
carry a gun he pulled it out try to show
him put it back and then when someone
asks like one more person asked him
again he pulled it out and then it
actually shot hey spaz he's 81 year old
dude Murr in a do know no interests
attack I hate talking about guns on the
show cuz everyone freaks out so just
chill you know I've guns now you know
just you know because if bad guys have
done good guys need gun knob so that's
the issue in the United States in
general but you know your your kids are
11 times more likely to die by sense
when you have them in the household yes
that's true I was reading the statistics
out see that's my number one problem
concerned yeah it's a real thing y'all
lock them up
you gotta lock them up the best thing to
do is have them locked with your
fingerprint on so you can just put your
fingerprint on it because a lot of times
somebody's in your house people forget
the combination unless you practice that
[ __ ] they forget and then and also
there's not loaded and the it's like
it's a so it's a lead weight you know if
you're serious about it you gotta have
you have it ready to go rehearse it -
yeah you rehearse but the statistics on
having a gun have you ever seen the
statistics and I'm having a gun inside
your house yeah not good
yeah so if you're like out some
offensive I've always been and I'll be
completely honest about this I don't
give a [ __ ] about you gun [ __ ] I've
always been anti-gun I don't I I think
it's why we have a problem in America
and stuff like that but I've had some
issues you know so I was talking the cop
is like to be honest I think should get
gun stuff like that and I did research
on it you look at the research and most
the research points to especially we
have a family of not having a gun I just
want a gun I'm sure I'm gonna get some
people no actually here's the reason why
I should have it I get that I read that
too but when you look at the statistics
of domestic abuse children you know
dying from gun suicide suicide there's a
lot of when they talk about gun violence
when I talk about all those people are
killed by guns every year one of the
things that the left always leaves out
is the fact that most of those gun but
most the gun violence is actually from a
suicide domestic and domestic and also
also like young men in crime so like
like gang crime on correct yeah that was
all the statistic for me I just want I
guess for me it's an emotional thing I
just like having an answer in case some
[ __ ] comes to my in my door you
know that's just how I feel so you know
and I don't think there's really there's
no consensus on calm control it's like I
think trying to I think the thing about
gun control and trying to make guns
control guns is a little bit like trying
to control drugs I don't think when
there's that much demand and that much
you know for a gun and whatever whatever
reason all the different reasons just
just like there are for drugs it's
really hard to control human behavior
and I don't see how you could legislate
that but I don't either
and my thing is in
don't want to get into by at a personal
issue with it where I've always been
anti-gun know when you go through
something like that yeah I'm like well
find a gun yep
you know and the guys who the bad guys
who had guns that had an issue with well
I don't have them I'll see if they don't
have comes to come to my house even if
it's three of them I could probably do
some work I'm fine
did you ever they're not gonna come to
my house without being on yeah do you
ever see the video of their there was
this group of like four dudes that were
coming into houses with like serious
guns like ak-47 shotguns they would kick
a door in and come in and just robbed
the [ __ ] out of people and this one guy
I think was a jeweler or he was whatever
he was and he it was in his neighborhood
they were doing this and he knew he was
gonna be next and you see them on his
honest camera how dumb Carolyn you see
them just break on the door and come
running into his house and the next
thing you know you see them running
shotguns I'm he's there getting shot at
and their windows of their car breaking
yeah he's coming allowed to do that yeah
I got one for you
I got one fraid this isn't gonna relate
but just remind me of that video and my
boy Todd told me about this I haven't
seen myself I'm shrinking and find it
chin there was this dad oh oh there was
this dad that walked in I think it was a
babysitter or a neighbor molesting his
kid yeah I know dad beat him so bad the
dude looks like Elephant Man the dad
calls the cops goes you better send
someone fast the cops like why he's a
commission and it's because I caught
this guy sexually molesting my child and
I beat the [ __ ] out of him
he might have another five minutes to
live I beat him there's an inch of his
life you better get sewn hair and when
scum gets the guy off the arrest him you
know what the cops do a reality that
another way they did show the sheriff
and he's like it's yeah like that's what
happens yeah
we actually did this as a current event
a long time ago he got 11 year old boy
he got beat there's a video of an 18
year old is accused of raping a boy he
was supposed to be babysitting police in
Daytona Beach say the suspect was caught
in the act by the victim's father the
suspect was arrested just after 1:00
this morning when the victim's father
returned home to find him in bed
with the eleven-year-old WESH 2's Claire
Metz reports the father made sure the
suspect didn't get away yeah
before raymond fro Lander was taken to
the Volusia County jail accused of
sexually battering an 11-year old boy he
was brought to Halifax Health Medical
Center to be treated badly beaten
according to police by the victim's
father the suspect appeared in court his
eyes almost swollen shut his face a
roadmap of rage but police say the man
who did it is not facing charges chief
my children [ __ ] right the rape
victim did what he would do I'd like to
kill him that he's acting like a father
protecting his country Luna and he's
furious over what has occurred I just
walked in from the cloak man molest him
and I got him in a bloody puddle for you
like now officer police say suspect fro
Lander and scored 11 year old boy first
to sit on his lap then took him into a
bedroom pulled his pants down and the
child's sexually battering him
that's the scissors look he's not dead
they're walked in on reacting then
calling 911 person who was thought these
do you not he's gonna need one
give me the Hammers eating you if you
hard enough to kill him when they're
telling me a story my god I don't know
if I have the the restraint nut fighting
is the guy thing is one of the greatest
evils man oh my god but also don't
highlight deser baby that's out yeah
that's also don't have an 1803 kids can
watch Mike yeah three people in Watchmen
that's the first rule I tell you never
ever ever ever a boy you never have a
boy a male never never have that and I'm
sorry it's not I'm sure there are plenty
of male nannies but don't care I'll
never have told care oh never happy a
come in my house and watch my son having
male nanny I have so many question here
if he's a eunuch it's not happening I
don't give a [ __ ] if you dress up like
mrs. Doubtfire that is where that is
where you discriminate that's where I
discriminate yep I will always be that
way janab male nannies I don't know that
dude me neither
Kenan Milne I trust I trust a woman
don't trust a man pretty much said it
yep that's not being chauvinistic just
being realistic it's my kid it's funny
when you got a kid where all the [ __ ]
goes out the window it's like I told you
this one also like felt Lansky Roman
Polanski the hypocrisy in Hollywood
these [ __ ]
petition to free him 2008 okay when he
got arrested in Switzerland me and my
dad were talking about this Roman
Polanski who raped a 13 year old you're
signing a petition is that what you're
doing in Hollywood it you guys standing
up I can't do it I can't do it
yeah you know came over if you did that
great artists great great director
scumbag you know I might do that guy I'm
I bash his eyen so bad where he's just
gonna have one eye for Louis's life so
he remembers me you know I'm saying yeah
I think so he's Johnson should I do is
done anyway
not really well no in other words he's
now a child convicted child molester he
gets still harm much children nice crew
you know I might do I meant there's some
satanic [ __ ] but this what happens when
you have a kid I'm gonna take a knife
and write rapists on his forehead yeah
you can do that and then no job and you
know I'm you know that's from a movie
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo but she
does on his chest god I got was such a
dude on his face yeah well that's Harvey
Weinstein yeah that's exactly who that
character is that therapist right
yeah it's Ari Weinstein well that
character was even more like Harvey
Weinstein was manipulative in begging
like a simpering weird like please
please don't embarrass me this guy was
taking advantage somebody who couldn't
say how great of it up how great was
seen is that she forgot about him
audible right I think Pig right she
wrote a Nazi Pig or rapist pig or
something yeah I'd write child molester
with a tattoo gun maybe or something
something like that something cool
sometimes the story I was gonna say [ __ ]
yeah you can see that dad there's some
mammoths he's gonna need it
[ __ ] yes you want to take over this you
sent me this bad boy oh I sent this to
Brian to again and I'm sick of timeout
sexual assault and the Hollywood stuff
as much as everyone's here about about
listening to us talk about it but I
thought this was so interesting because
everyone think oh and I get this even
from people go got Hollywood right when
I'm on the road Hollywood's crazy how
it's great no no Hollywood's just what
you're hearing about this happens in
every industry in the world
we're malnourished but even though
thousands thousands of years no reso
this article was in The Huffington Post
was housekeepers and the sexual assault
yes well do to answer the door naked or
they're jerking off whatever it is so
scroll up scroll up chin so that the
title is it says low-wage workers have
been fighting sexual harassment for
years the national conversation is
finally catching up with him because
Hollywood kind of sparked it and now
it's do you know what I never do I was
thinking about this cramming hotels all
the time
I never tip my cleaning lady because I
don't know how like like there's never
like I've never seen a tip thing for
them and I don't see I don't think
you're supposed to because if you leave
it there yeah you know they're like oh
that I can't that's what I mean so like
if you leave money for them they're
gonna feel like well maybe he left it
and it's not a tip so how do you do it
cuz they need tips
you always leave it on the dresser I've
never seen it I don't know
have you seen Jay we grew up in Houston
I say there's no no pad yet no that's
sometimes maybe sometimes maybe I don't
see it uh no what the hell what they as
you put it
dude I tip like a [ __ ] so I got
a stick man uh your it's when your trip
is over right when you're in Vegas for
like a weekend I got to start still on
on the Sunday you leave leave it next to
where you're like their lap is you just
put money there we always do it I'm a
scumbag it's a weird thing that a lot of
people don't know about it though [ __ ]
it's like it it's just something you do
that I've known that since I've started
at Vegas yeah oh you don't piss me off
in Nashville at this Veterans Day I had
this young kid 22 23 maybe but he was in
the military just driving uber just to
make up you know means he's trying to
you know pay the bills and I said happy
Veterans Day man he's like finally
someone says it he was like an American
flag hanging off his rearview mirrors
dog tags I'm like oh yeah I mean so
we're talking and then you just talking
about you know how they don't get paid
much and you don't have a lot of money
do things and you think I'm driving over
cuz last night I went out my buddies and
got way too hammered and I didn't have
the money so I'm paying for it now so
into an uber
I'm like Veterans Day I'm gonna hook
this dude up I knew where I'm getting
like a 500 tick that's what I'm gonna do
to you know to his veteran thing I get
on uber to give him a huge [ __ ] tip
and he can't do it they give you a Mac
they go give him I don't hide never have
cash do you it says either give him cash
or the maxim I can tip is $13 because
the ride was like six dollars you can
only double it
you can't give my fat tip how [ __ ] up
is that ice [ __ ] up that's cool you
though I'm gonna pin I didn't call any
of my [ __ ] or texted me and my
military friends and thank them for
their service is that what I should do
on Veterans Day I don't think so
we have text everyone who's a military
not just my friends yeah you always talk
well about him over here anyway it's
like all the time so I'm sure they know
how much you appreciate him yeah I do
Tex um Merry Christmas Oh what else you
got you let me know that goes for
another one pink so I'm not sure if you
were talking about Christina Aguilera
singing Whitney Houston song yes that's
me talking okay so yeah Christina
Aguilera did a tribute to Whitney
Houston and she did like three or four
of her songs so check until Whitney
Houston for God's sake so AMAs I see I
don't think and we can play some not
hold on for us in Judaea I don't think
anyone should have sang Whitney Houston
songs because she's a
once-in-a-generation voice so anyone who
sings it is gonna get hate so for
Christina Aguilera is an amazing voice
she put whit not like wooden heels she
could she can she can if anybody can do
it it's her though right
she was really good before good she was
really good before pink cringe uh no she
wasn't she wasn't Chris you just like
we're saying that she was cuz you say
this she I think she was just listening
to it but so I watched it and I just
went mad I feel I feel like no one
should be doing Whitney Houston like
she's just such you're gonna it's almost
career suicide because whoever was like
yeah they're looking for because I'm
sure a lot of people turned it down and
Christina had letters like I'll do it
you know I haven't sang in years no man
she's out of the business she doesn't
know she is the voice now is she used to
yeah well the comparison so no matter
and I thought Christina did great but
you know black chimeric was like why the
[ __ ] is this girl singing Whitney
Houston it's a lose/lose like even if
you do well it's a what is angular if
she's Latin she's some kind of Latin can
you can you just play a little clip yes
here
like I said it's good
[Music]
oh but I I'll think of you every step of
the way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's amazing she's qualified it's a mega
dam she's amazing she got so much for
this you got [ __ ] for this you don't get
better see this is people who just don't
understand the effort that takes Wow is
she talented I just think like it's just
a it's a no-win situation but I don't
even I applaud her even Whitney couldn't
do Whitney later right
yeah Wendy could rock here can't do
Mariah Carey later in life either oh
lady I'll get it something happens yeah
it's just your voice I was in like for
her man inside she hasn't done anything
in a long just oh god it's of her to
come she suffer her to come back to
which she doesn't have what she used to
never see Aguilera no I disagree no this
is the first time actually if you hear
other like the rest of the song you can
tell she's not as good as she's not your
ass is the world like you just heard her
in the second clip he's been gone for
five years let me hear the reason you
know who could have done this though I
think Beyonce or no Jennifer Hudson oh
no no no you're just not in the know you
like you don't watch it well but yes but
you know I'll tell you who could of them
who's the young girl whose name
oh crap I know you're talking about that
ponytail she sounds like ariana grande
yes yes she could she could do it
so ariana grande did a Whitney Houston
cover for Obama looked that up and look
at the devasting ariana grande who's 21
yeah in her prime and that cuz cuz she
aware she's not touring anyone she's not
she's not singing the way she was think
about it does you know I'm saying like
this journey sound like journey when
they're [ __ ] 16 I didn't know she
would stop singing I mean I'm Marius
which one is it I have nothing yes life
at the White House know that this is the
one life for Obama have you heard her be
[Applause]
she's actually really good educated I'm
ready man I love this [ __ ] so much I get
emotional I see how good these people
are look at her this tiny gal
[Applause]
good evening I feel so incredibly you
don't have a shot cuz you're white but
keep watching she was expected um so
thank you for having me be a part well
actually her boyfriend's right now god
bless Mac Miller
yeah he's as white as against
countrywide sham versus Jew mine's a
Christie Aguilera by the way they're
right in front of her bro
[Music]
[Music]
for you
[Music]
and everything that you do
Oh
[Music]
not her best not a rest now she's
nervous
it's definitely nervous right now how
long ago is this well I'll see bombs in
the White House yeah let's do that fits
off when you're nervous your body's a
little tight whether or not you know
it's just it would be cute yeah - yeah I
mean that's really by the way Android a
has got something to say
Andrew dates me is as good as anybody
ever ever like and today hmm
you might want to look it up andr and
Renee how old is she you know that rise
up good put rise up on there and uh she
know she's amazing the black waiting yes
she's just saying dick you I mean whoo
like I literally when she sang that
tribute to the Bee Gees and stuff you
know she's amazing she's just incredible
right there Alicia Keys things rise up
with with her today I mean I guess but
you can just hear you can just hear her
on if you actually just hear her on the
other it's ridiculous
as good as I bet you they offered this
gig to them and they're like no mother
and her lived in a one-bedroom I mother
with driver to LA for voice lessons from
San Diego super tempted are listening to
hey guys sorry yeah I thought that was
interred with scam Aguilar who I'm a fan
of when she's doing like ah no matter
and right before I returned to Jowitt no
matter what no matter how this goes
social medias can destroy her cuz you
know it's just it's Whitney Houston yeah
you know it's just the a little love for
the effort god damn ah I thought yeah it
was good amazing pink pink pink tit
upper for a thin weird she hung off did
you see a channel she hung off the JW
Marriott and did like her song they're
really awkward you be honest it was
awkward
I love pink but I was watching I'm like
you know why can't just have a stage and
perform like she's not even really
singing there's these at rope acrobats
they're hanging off yeah building yeah
I'm like alright max used to always say
hit say it's too much when you're in
when you're in your artist when you're
an actor when you're a comedian when
whatever you are you're you're good at
try things and a lot of times you might
fail but fail spectacularly and he said
and don't criticize anybody else because
it's gonna affect our the HISP of offer
yes that's really a you can see it but
it's gonna affect his tough talk well
first of all that's what you see
[Music]
but the camera can't get that claw so
it's like yeah well is she singing it
now she's lip singing so yeah that
doesn't look great it's off course stuff
why do that it was an idea again these
all right soldier like who's like Kate
what do you think about Peter singer an
artist sauce bro what about her hanging
up the side of JW Marriot yeah but the
qu6 then we'll just play the track yeah
cuz money's paid cuz the checks of
Khitan been cut and then everybody's
gonna go it was [ __ ] amazing when you
do anything remember this right
everything is amazing it's always
amazing it's the best thing ever this
people are gonna freak out it's an
incredible idea it's never been done and
it is a good idea just the execution of
it is a little tough I mean I like that
it just looks like they're on a floor
though that's just weird
yeah because it's it's shot like they're
on it so it looks awkward just other
things didn't do it for me what else
gets in I get it I get it the Trump and
Lavar ball stuff thing cracks god I
should have left him in jail yes oh you
know yes the same guy the the guys I
admitted fault that they were stealing
and then Donald Trump said uh do you
think they'll thank me and after that
came out wait so Donald said well do you
people think me first right and then
they had that press conference and they
actually thanked him and then ESPN had
an interview with levar ball who's the
father there's a father here yeah and he
was saying like who he had nothing to do
with three UCLA basketball players I say
you're welcome go up please this way no
the other way right there to the three
UCLA basketball players let's say you're
welcome
go out and give a big THANK YOU to
President Xi Jingping of China who made
you relate your released possible and
have a great life be careful there are
many pitfalls and long and winding road
of life that what president claps
himself on the back yeah thank you so
you're not gonna really address delivery
public the mass shootings dude he's in
you address this he's a narcissist is he
that's what he said narcissist so this
is how Olive art says his name is Lavar
right I keep them mixed up they go yes
who what was he over there for don't
tell me nothing everybody wants to make
it seem like he helped out well he did
so after that Trump responded he did now
the three basketball players were out of
trying to save years in jail Lavar ball
the father of Lee Angelo is unaccepting
of what I did for his son and that
shoplifting is no big deal
I should have left them in jail
shoplifting is a very big deal in China
as it should be five ten years in jail
but not to father Lavar should have
gotten his son out during my next trip
to China instead trying to tell them why
they were released very ungrateful what
bearson he's amazing he's amazing this
is what we do magic bombs he throws any
of them tweeted out this stuff he's here
he's the most unpresidential press so
crazy what else you got you know I can't
although Lavar balls somebody said that
the coach said hey media how about not
giving either one of them any attention
maybe that would help though the
difference is I mean Lavar ball it's
actually a beast of a dad all three sons
when to call you know I'm saying you see
I know but but Trump market I guess get
him out so a little thank you right but
they kids they say things yeah but I
mean he shouldn't become president
shouldn't be tweeting that you don't
need gratification and thank you some
civilians yes he does Leo said it best
about handling all this went pro you're
the [ __ ] president this is your job
yeah like that's your job man that's
what you're supposed to do it's always
about him
Trump has that's his default well Artie
Lyon told me that on Stern he had he had
roasted Trump and so Trump is on stun
and and Trump goes is very funny Artie
was sensational
and then already started doing they they
played what the jokes work because Trump
actually wasn't listening to him and
asked after they're done Trump goes
you're a loser
and just turn lose your loser you're a
loser like dead hard it was like let me
out was sensational like that hurt your
feelings though if you're like doing
pressing it and because from Trump
I'd like your on others in my back caddy
I worked with a they were called by
Trump goes and they're at his at his
club and he goes Javan idea how lucky
you guys are turn the caddy is how do
you think I'm doing
and my caddy goes the caddy goes you got
a lot on your plate it seems like you're
handling it well him being president
yeah how do you think I'm doing good man
thank y'all for good golfer apparently
and funny don't give a [ __ ] I don't want
my president get a golf what else
addiction I got one MMA one and I think
you know what this is already
no I don't fall knose Damir arrested for
felony battery is a bar fight incentive
but from what I hear yeah faded himself
that's what his lawyers are saying yeah
fight it was in August don't fight him
do you not see his ears what's a wise in
a bar but to if he was defend himself
hopefully they don't yank him off the
title might but I who knows what the
real reports are geez there you go yeah
it was a altercation a bar hey man if if
you're if you're about to fight for a
title shot let's not hang out at bars
late at night yeah but you just go out
for a drink you know yeah well I don't
know what he's gonna do I mean what I
wonder if the guy had any idea what he
was dealing with I wonder what happened
exactly I will hopefully find out what
it charges crazy it says something like
it caused like possibly permanent
disfigurement early disability break
somebody sure
okay hopefully it's self-defense and
he'll press you know he doesn't get you
can't imagine him being the aggressor of
all people I don't know I know but it
just seems it wouldn't be first of all I
don't like also you're a don't fight
that guy I guess you didn't if any fight
are you gonna pick on for some reason he
just seems like there are toughness out
there there are tough guys out there had
a lot of bar fights and they figure he's
gonna be just a regular guy and then
I realized very quickly Oh No why have
you waited in the world
Oh No Sochi in Florida I mean that's the
stomping grounds some phenomenal mixed
martial artists you just don't have any
idea you know not this day and age what
else get Jim another teacher with a
student case yeah look at her and she's
22 years old and she's married to the
the coach of the same school and she
should not have with him there's a 17
year old boy was but that's earth is
very hot I can I where was I my teachers
with my trolls I never hit him I know
where was everybody yeah yeah and what
exactly was she doing this she saw the
points going down when investigators
entered the home day was sailing the
Florida living room with candles lit all
the lights laughs just wearing Kiska all
right yeah she had the lights off also
he sent some dick pigs so what happened
was the parents felt like this the
student was acting strange all of a
sudden and then they checked his phone
he can tell that the teacher was texting
with him so they the investigators
pretended that they were the guy and
then had them meet up and they showed up
on the front she for sure sleep with a
kid yeah and she's charged with also
with child pornography because the kid
was sent you know like dick pics that's
weird 17 yeah seven come on isn't there
a difference between 17 and six or 17
and 11 to 13 and 14 the given II as a
boy deeply was psyched I can't what if
at 17 with a 22 year old I would have
been like it's all downhill from here my
man man you just hit the lot of height
this one might not be the 17th this one
didn't show the age I think the other
one that I'm gonna show you was 17 so
this one you know what that penalty is
that you just can't do it right I'd be I
feel like we should get her out then you
got the substitute is 23 had sex with
two guys two - yeah
boom this one I mean oh no no this one's
uh 20 yeah this is 23 she's a
cheerleader coach cheerleader coach and
that's known that she had a sexy she had
sex with a 17 year old kid she hold a
she
three young super young she is young and
hooked up with seventeen-year-old so
five years apart but yet if a 25 year
old a 30 year old hook up there's no
problem I know it's one of those weird
areas where the law hasn't been
objective but usually 17 I thought there
was like extenuating circumstances
what's the state it was consensual
though and the parents can excuse it
there's all kinds of stuff right there
so the excuse of this my dad are you
serious no you're not pressing charges
she's 22 I'm like dad she's my dad no I
get I get it let me show you these
pictures yeah yeah yeah man yeah I have
a rock-hard boner social studies all
body 17 your boy yeah that's everybody
want to send it a prison for what being
awesome come on dad come on dad I'm
sorry it's true I mean I don't know like
that's at 17 I would have been like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] I had we I had two teachers
like that we were all of us guys all
guys at 17 were like she's so hot you
know work for them don't you get Jim I
got one more I don't know if we want to
talk about this because it's also this
sexual thing but it seems like I told
the judge this judge he's a Supreme
Court judge judge Bill O'Neil and after
the Al Franken stuff came out you know
the sexual thing was began tweeting this
guy wrote on his own Facebook but it's
actually a little funny the way he
writes this so you want to read it now
that the dogs of war are calling for the
head of senator Al Franken I believe
it's time to speak up on behalf of all
heterosexual males as a candidate for
governor let me save my opponent some
research time in the last 50 years of
sexually intimate with approximately 50
very attractive female that marry it
rain well it ranged from gorgeous
personal secretary to Senator Bob Taft
who was my first true love and we made
passionate love in the hayloft of her
parents bar and well blows end with a
drop-dead gorgeous redhead who was a
senior advisor Pierre Lewis and we
aggressively insurance in Cleveland now
we can get back to discussing legalizing
marijuana and opening the State Hospital
Network to come at the opioid crisis so
he's waiting for so disappointed by this
national feeding frenzy about sexual
indiscretions decade
to go peace take some guts to write it
and I think he's got a point where he
wants to get back to work that's a lie
yeah my last 50 years of sick [ __ ] was a
proxy I can you know what again when you
come out and you're honest and you have
no secrets man well look at home mister
steal your girl god bless you 50 son god
bless you all he's doing is just saying
here's what I did let me get back to my
work now yeah right that's all okay
there's a lot of there's a lot of
refreshing stuff in that it's it's you
know it's in the shack at the gig though
a lot of people were against what he
said but then there's a lot of people
said that you just earned my vote after
doing that of course I hope he wins he's
been any clarified it but just basically
you guys said so hard again bro this
Benji Connolly let's go here's an
interesting optimistic note dropping
knowledge wise I think that we are
making progress as a people and I think
what's interesting is that we all use
the same kind of words and concepts and
even values to bolster our side of the
argument but we're using the same
language I thought of this when I heard
of rate like even racists don't like
being called racists it's hilarious
I heard this white supremists go I'm not
racist I'm just Pro white and I thought
to myself how interesting that racism
that's not that's ugly progress but
ironically at least it's kind of like a
guy saying an avowed race is clearly a
[ __ ] dummy saying this and I was
thinking about how who he used the same
language so liberals the end of the left
wing in the right wing you got the
liberals to talk about immigration they
say you know we need we need immigration
immigration is a good thing and you know
yes illegal immigration is bad but we
should let me give them you know a road
to immunity in a road to you know
legalization and the right goes no law
and order
lorilynn has to be respected okay and
then you have the right who basically
says you know guns are our choice Second
Amendment and the [ __ ] left goes no
we need
laws we need more law and order so one
size calling for law and order when it
comes to immigration the other side's
calling for law and order when it comes
to guns take abortion one side is
pro-choice and the other side says no
life is sacred
but then this side that calls for life
is sacred says we should have the death
penalty and that's the that's exactly
when the left goes no life is sacred so
we're using the same exact values to
bolster our side of the argument even
though there are different topics it's
very interesting that we at least we
share the same language and that's
actually pretty unique to history right
now we don't talk anymore about the idea
that there are people that are better
because they were born better that is so
taboo that would get you run out of town
and now it's all about the idea that we
are basically equal no matter what and
that all of us have a right to our own
self-determination all of us have a
right to our own sort of feelings and
our feelings a lot of times and I think
this is a bad thing our feelings are
more important like we usually you can
say well I feel like such and such is
the case and everybody has to go okay I
have to respect your feelings I think
that's a bad thing I don't think your
feelings matter as much of in terms of
how you think I'd rather hear you say I
think I think this because of this not I
feel this way I think your feelings are
not I don't care how you feel it's
probably a bad idea to come up with an
argument that way even though you can't
really separate your feelings from your
thoughts but it seems to me that
thoughts are taking a backseat of
feelings and take a look at that and
think about that the next time you hear
a political debate where you hear people
talk on TV it's an interesting thing
how feelings are sort of our new
religion I got a feeling in being you
tall thin though god damn right that's a
futile one that too ed that's a [ __ ]
good yeah you're gonna be a new tall
brother wait he didn't you know I dug it
man alright I guess you're ready to end
this [ __ ] yeah I got the message I'm
gonna be at wiseguys this Friday
Saturday Oh guys it's great
it's a great but I feel like you're
gonna have good time do you feel that
way I need to know how you think what
everybody feeling what do you think what
do you think I think it's gonna be a
good time all right that's great by the
way we don't feel like to fear is that
feelings of thinking or art differ
connectable the difference but they're
different but there unless you're white
supremacist right and then then I'm not
racist I'm just throw white thank you
thank you buddy
I didn't ramble a little bit yeah thank
you for getting me honest I thought if I
had a warm bath in US every night I
would I'm into it what is that how you
feel that's one thing okay but I made
you feel that way therefore you thought
about yes we did then um well no you're
gonna do a podcast for turkey day so but
I feel like Turkey sucks
and I think Turkey sucks and I think
you're gonna be it wise guys wise guys
and then you know what December 7th 8th
and 9th if you're in San Francisco I'm a
cop and guess what
Cobb's brightly give a [ __ ] I feel
[ __ ] no like dropping knowledge will
you [ __ ] you up
we binding everybody know we even think
about that but you can you can let all
you think you know I thought [ __ ]
feelings right here I feel like you're
being insensitive right now Bob's on it
Salt Lake yeah I was interesting one
brother and I'm an Ontario improv
November 30th I'm at The Comedy Store
tonight but times comes out your pride
too late you say hell yeah yeah but the
big deals are Ontario improv November
30th then I'm in Buffalo they might a
little birdie told me they're adding
Syracuse to that Buffalo run who's I
might be in Syracuse on Wednesday night
Buffalo Friday Saturday might be
Thursday Friday Saturday you'll figure
it 16th to the 19th I'm in Buffalo God's
a helium-filled call me Clara if it
snows in my cloud you're doing it now if
it snows I don't have to be there so
what are you doing at Syracuse what club
I don't know they looked x-man's drive
just text me two hour drive all right
we'll see oppression of said anything
kiss on concrete
either way Buffalo 16 for the 19th get
your tickets now tea vodka calm for
Brian and myself I
feel like you should do it's right I
feel I think yeah
your feelings don't matter yep that
thank you although I I feel and think
that our feelings and thoughts carry
separate yes uh thank you guys this has
been a great fantastic fight okay once
you sign Sal Brennan this is a fired kid
[ __ ] your feelings were out
[Laughter]